attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge mais qu'est ce tu fous là je
vais récupérer mes affaires
un bas d'accord doivent à dire entre
comme chez toi sauf que battante et chez
moi mais tu sais que je t'aime encore
d'ailleurs je continue à envoyer des sms
que j'ai un peu d'espoir de récupérer
j'essaye d'en montrer vrai qu'est-ce
qu'on arrive le poème avec les smileys
que lorsque nous a fait deux jours elle
chérit regarde si ces cas là c'est le
poète salut mais il suffirait tu m'as
dit que tu serais pas là quand je
récupérer mes affaires
oui mais je n'avais pas envie que tu vas
le détruit pendant mon absence jallet
rien volé peut-être pisser sur ta brosse
à dents à la limite mais elle permet d
eux
merci à temps c'est mon tee shirts ouais
bah ouais moi je les aime bien donc du
coup les gars des bons pour la
répartition des meubles la table elle
est trop grosse un donc je la laisse par
contre comme c'est moi qui l'avais
acheté si tu peux vous rembourser 200
euros tu t'es blessé bijoux bon je te
laisse la vaisselle la télé on fait
comment battus peut la reprendre
car très peu la télé avec bruno mieux
qu'on a une vie sexuelle très épais
nombreux j'ai compris qu'ils achetaient
la portée des trucs bas ma fierté me dit
non mais mon corps me dit oui donc si tu
peux prendre la télé ça m'arrange voilà
la bonne façon nous on s'en sert pas si
tu vois ce que je veux dire mais j'ai
vraiment compris au fait qu'un jeu rend
les clés même si je fais un doublé en
clôture on appelle ça risque pas
d'arriver
et puis tu peux regarder au fait changer
les serrures demain mais un doublé de ma
grand mère avec un liseré d'or oui voilà
bah c'est ça que j'ai pété jusqu'au bout
dans la peau du cul toi
[Musique]